[Music]
for the last couple months I've been
working on a full ionic for fire based
course where we build a fully
cross-platform mobile app and I'm happy
to announce today that it is finally
available for enrollment the best way to
access it is for free by being a pro
member but if you just want this one
course I'll also leave a discount code
here on YouTube the focus of this
initial version of the course is to
really focus on the fundamentals it
covers important topics that often get
overlooked like project structure and
developer happiness and it goes into
detail about how components and services
interact with each other to build out
actual features all features are
designed to work on the web iOS and
Android including user authentication
and push notifications then you'll learn
pretty much everything you need to know
about routing and cross component
communication by building a real-time
to-do list with firestore then we'll
wrap up the course with deployment to
the web iOS and Android now if you're
thinking a to-do list is a pretty boring
demo I agree with you 100% it's just
really good at showcasing the
fundamentals of ionic but that's why I
want to put an extension to this course
up to a vote a lot of different requests
for features in this course have been
made but I want you to tell me what I
should prioritize and whatever gets the
most votes will be the first extended
feature for this course the poll will be
held on our slack Channel and I'll give
away a free one of a kind t-shirt to one
lucky voter so now that we have a good
foundation for this course it opens up
the door for extended features like
firebase analytics and predictions we
could build a geolocation feature using
map box or Google Maps we could do a
more complex fire store exercise like
building a whatsapp clone where we might
build out an image based feature that
uses firebase storage and some of
Google's machine learning libraries I'll
just let you decide by voting aside from
that I just want to let you know that
the course is intermediate level so
you'll definitely want to have some
experience with JavaScript and it will
also help if you're familiar with
typescript and angular I think that's
all the information I have for now I
look forward to chatting with you about
the course and I'll talk to you soon
you